- This is hard work.
Buzzfeed, I thought I could be a writer,
but now I'm kind of tired.
- (laughs)
(light music)
- Oh wait, can I go first?
I'm going to introduce Bobby.
This is Bobby Berk, Interior
Designer on Queer Eye, Netflix,
and not only is he a gorgeous designer,
but he also has flawless typing skills.
Please don't stop typing.
He's fake typing now, but
before he was real typing,
and he was really, really good.
- This is Jonathan Van Ness.
He is our gorgeous, I'm
saying gorgeous too much.
But he's our gorgeous groomer.
The thing that I love
most about Jonathan is
he's not that groomer who is
going to tell you what you need,
he's that groomer that's
going to listen to you
and help you be the best version
of what you think you should be.
- Unless you're really out of control.
- Well, then yeah, then
he's going to take control,
like with my hair in season one.
He took my control of that.
- I did do that.
- And look at it now.
Thank you!
- Hey, this is Antoni.
He's perfect in every way.
That face is gorgeous,
his cooking is gorgeous.
- I was going to say, look at that hair,
but I forget you haven't
washed it in a while,
so I'm not going to.
- I washed it four days ago.
- This the longest intro
I've ever know for a quiz.
- I think we should make a 30 minute video
of us just introducing each other.
- I'm going to introduce Karamo so that
Tan can figure out how
to introduce himself.
What I love about Karamo
is that he is so in tune with who he is
that he has managed to take this role
and really make it into something
completely different and unexpected.
- (high voice) I'm Tan France!
- (high voice) That's Tan France!
And he's our fashion stylist and expert,
and he's got really tall hair.
- And great legs.
Look at these legs.
- Now lets do this quiz.
- That you're going to take!
- Oh my God, you type like me.
- I know.
- You type like a seven-year-old
who's never seen a computer.
- [Tan] Do you backcombing your roots?
- I'm a little textured out.
- You did your chest?
Oh it's good.
- It's good, right?
- It's really good.
- Thanks.
- You have the good rivets here.
- Like the little- the crack of hazelnut!
- Feel it.
- They're really good.
- It's good, right?
- I'm really muscly too!
- You guys okay?
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- I got a little jealous.
- My favorite transformation-
Oh, you know who it is?
- Wait, that's going to be our question?
- Yeah, this is the question.
- Our favorite transformation?
My favorite transformation of the moment
is just because of the interaction-
shush!
(record screech)
(Jonathan scoffs)
- Fame has really gotten to you, Antoni.
It really has.
I really need you to, like,
cool it down a little bit.
Who was your favorite transformation?
- It was Jeremy, because he
did the hot dogs with his kids,
and he got to hang out
with his kids making
condiments for the hot dogs.
- Wait, should we make
it about season two?
- No, 'cause the question is season one.
- Shut up, I didn't see it!
- [Kamaro] Now choose a drag race queen
to be your drag mother.
- Jujubee.
- You choose one for
me, 'cause I don't know.
- Jiggly Caliente.
- I pick Ru Paul.
If I'm going to learn, I'm
going to learn from the best.
- I love Jujubee for everyone.
I think she's the most, like, underrated
of all drag queens of all time.
- Jonathan, who's your other one?
- Maybe Thorgie.
I like a Thorgie's mole.
- Ew, Thorgie?
- Yeah, I like him.
He's very different.
- Antoni, I think you
are very much Valentina.
- You know what?
I forgot about Shange.
- Shange!
Oh my gosh.
- Shangela!
- Yeah, it's Shange.
I take Thorgie back.
- One of these things does not belong,
and it's these two who don't
know what we're talking about.
- We got to pick a dream date
to go on with your Queer Eye soulmate.
I would do a carnival for mine.
- You would do a carnival?
- I would recreate that music video
for "All Night Long".
- So you'd do a music video?
That would be your dream date?
- With my husband, I'd recreate it.
- It's cute, right?
Baby-making music.
- Mine's bracelet making.
- Aw, that was cute.
That was really chic.
- Mine would be shopping for
vintage mid century furniture
and a nice little brunch.
- I would do that with you.
- No, not shopping for furniture, no.
- But you can't put vintage furniture-
- Yes you can.
- Two completely different things, Karamo.
- You know, you're really putting
people in boxes today.
- [Tan] Oh, you love a picnic.
- Oh, God, Karamo's typing's
killing my Virgo-ness.
- [Kamaro] What are you saying?
- [Antoni] A is not capitalized.
- [Bobbi] A shouldn't be capitalized.
- Oh my gosh.
Everything else is capitalized.
- This is airing out some of our stuff.
I think what they're trying to say is that
sometimes your spelling
on your Instagram captions
makes them stressed out,
and they wanted to talk to
you about it for a little bit,
but they get nervous.
- Mine would be, like an
early May dinner in Rome.
And I would have high-waisted
trousers with my hands
in my pants, just like
strolling down the street.
- And no top?
- Zero top.
- [Kamaro] Lastly, choose a
song to play in the bedroom.
- Her, something by Her.
- I would say anything from Daniel Caesar.
- Oh I'm feeling something.
- Okay, who's yours?
- Goldfrapp, number one.
- Okay, what's your second one?
- Lana, 13 Beaches.
Don't say anything.
- She's great.
- Mine is Ooh La La from Goldfrapp.
- Keep typing - don't stop typing.
That typing was really working for me.
And he's like giving you a
gorgeous quiz moment right now!
- You got Bobby because
you like to keep it real.
You are always making sure
friends are taken care of.
You prefer a night at home
with your lifelong friends
than a chic Hollywood party.
- Wasn't that a good one?
What's yours say?
Kamaro, what are you writing?
- I'm writing the same line you did.
Okay, I said, you got Karamo because
you love being around other people.
You walk into a party ready to turn up
and connect with others.
Everyone you meet, you give a hug to.
You know who you are
and don't mind sharing it with the world.
- Can I fix your grammatical
and spelling errors?
- Completely.
- I wasn't going to address that one, but.
- Senators and Presidents always have
a team of people to
spell check their stuff.
So, he does not even need
to type, it's like fine!
- Know what you're good at
and know what you're not good at.
- Were you all great with that one?
- Yes.
- Okay, Good.
- What am I doing?
- You go to yours,
and you fill in why they got you.
- Do you love avocados?
(group laughs)
Do you love avocados and simple salads?
- Are you trying to figure out new and
innovative ways to use an avocado?
- You know what you should do girl?
A chocolate avocado mousse.
- Guys, I can't talk about
avocado while I write.
- 'Cause you're going to type,
avocado, avocado, avocado.
- And then also Greek yogurt.
- It's a long "o" - yoooogurt.
- Yogurt.
- Yooogurt.
- I walk in sometimes in the morning,
and he's got the white
yogurt all over his face.
- He's not even being a nightmare,
and at first, I like, let it go.
But he does do a very
gorgeous DIY Greek yogurt.
It's what keeps him so balanced.
- (clears throat) You got
Antoni because you are a
feeler of all the feels.
You love a good cheese-centric meal,
and nothing makes you
more happy than petting
a happy pepperoni, corgi, or other.
You love your friends and
close ones unconditionally.
Also, baths and candles.
- Honestly, if I worked at Buzzfeed
after seeing this video,
I'd be a little nervous.
We're literally, like, making
content on the fly, so well.
Like all you writers, honey,
you need to watch out, honey!
I will write quizzes
for the rest of my life.
Tanny, honestly, I'm
feeling a little like-
- Oh, you can type and look, oh!
- Tan and I can type and look.
- Tanny, honestly, I feel like
with your two-piece seersucker,
I feel like I can't really
concentrate because...
- Because this is creeping
higher and higher.
- We're like coworkers, and I feel, uh
you are just so pretty.
- Can you guys talk amongst
yourselves for a minute?
Just give me two minutes!
- Our mustaches have never looked more-
- They're more similar?
No, like in density and length,
I've always said that our
mustaches are the same.
- I think you two should grow beards.
Oh, you already have a beard.
Then you should grow a beard.
- He has a full beard.
- How many paragraphs are you doing?
- I was trying to do two.
- But they said three sentences.
- Gets one book deal, suddenly-
he's all fucking Hemingway.
Ooh, wee, oh, ahh.
- It's not my fault I was
good at English in school.
- You're welcome for that pitch.
- One has to wonder, are
these really my friends,
or are they actually nightmare tramps?
Tan, keep looking at me and typing.
Everyone thought that was really smart.
They didn't get a clean take on that-
- Wait, I'm trying to concentrate.
- It's like you've never done
unscripted television before.
Can you please look at me and type?
- You got it, right?
- No!
Tanny, they didn't get it.
- Look at me, Tanny, and do
it and really type stuff.
I also love to do brow gel,
and a little bit of mascara on my tips.
- No, Tan doesn't wear any makeup.
- I like your camo jacket.
- Thank you.
- I have some really slutty two-pieces
I'm going to wear for press.
- Slutty?
Like that?
You can all get away with it,
because you have smaller butts than me.
My butt and hips are too big.
It'd be like donkey-donk.
- Wait, I bet people are going to
start, like, asking to
get their noses done
to look more like your nose.
- Don't!
- Is it going to be like
Jennifer Aniston with her hair?
- I want my nose more
like yours right here.
Can we talk about the part of Tan's nose
that I'm obsessed with?
This part, like how it
connects into your face.
Like I'm obsessed with that.
- Okay, I've got it!
I'm done.
Do you see how much I was
distracted by this one?
- Read it aloud, Tanny.
- Okay, you got Tan
because you're a little
more direct than people might appreciate.
You love a strong fashion moment.
You understand the
importance of dressing to
get where you want to get in life.
You also love a boundary.
A strong, appropriate boundary.
- Johnny, come here, Johnny.
- Remember those
boundaries we talked about?
- No.
- Thank you, is it your turn?
- [Kamaro] That actually was really good.
- I'm like, what's my brand?
Like, who am I?
- Take your time. Just figure it out.
- You are in it, Johnny, you are in it.
The first line better be,
"I love the (bleep) four guys next to me."
I never cuss by the way.
- Got it!
- Do you see how we didn't distract you
whilst you were doing yours?
- [Bobby] All those red lines.
- Girl, I write how I talk.
Jonathan is your girl
because insurance commercials
can make you cry, you're
never afraid of a well-placed
power stomp, and obscure
sports and early 90s
MTV references make you feel complete.
Also, you love people and
won't let quiz results
ever dim your shine.
- [Kamaro] Yes!
I love the subtle shade
with the quiz results.
- Sorry.
This will be their first and last time
having talent do their own quiz.
- They are so over it.
I've been to enough auditions
to know how this works.
- We're not getting a call back.
It's fine.
- Do you need my...
No we don't need-
Head to buzzfeed.com to figure
out who your soulmate is.
- It's me.
- [Jonathan] I'm so really into the
emphasis that you put on YOUR soulmate.
(upbeat music)